familiendrama im saarland in saarbrücken
war eine 38 jährige gestern abend ihre
kinder gerade mal ein und drei jahre alt
aus dem ersten stock ihres hauses die
frau sprang danach selber in die tiefe
die dreijährige tochter starb das ein
jahr alte geschwister hin hatte einen
schutzengel blieb nahezu unversehrt die
frau liegt im koma ein
ermittlungsverfahren wegen versuchten
und vollendeten mordes gegen die frau
wurde eingeleitet es gibt hinweise auf
einen psychischen ausnahmezustand dieser
frau und wir schalten direkt zu unserem
kollegen lassen so pinter nach
saarbrücken ja lassen was für ein
schreckliches drama das sich da
abgespielt hat was kannst du uns zu den
hintergründen sagen ja hallo hier ist
thomas wir sind wir sind noch erforschen
was hintergründe das waren die polizei
ist nur sie gehen von einem psychischen
ausnahmezustand der frau aus sie ist
noch nicht ansprechbar wurde jetzt aber
nach unserem wissensstand ins
uniklinikum nach homburg verlegt und das
ist momentan der stand der dinge
gibt es schon informationen zu den
hintergründen wie es zu diesem drama kam
wir haben eben gesagte die frau hat sich
in einem psychischen ausnahmezustand
befunden soll sich in so einem zustand
befunden haben hast du da weitere
informationen für uns lediglich haben
wir mit nachbarn gesprochen das waren
aber nicht diejenigen schon vor der tat
haben nachbarn hier die polizei gerufen
und
darauf hin dass die polizei ausgerückt
und das war dann leider gottes aber zu
spät du sagst gerade das mit nachbarn
gesprochen konnten die ein bisschen mehr
über diese familie erzählen sind die
forschen in irgendeiner form auffällig
gewesen auf keinen fall ist eine sehr
gut besuchte verbindet zu sein der
großvater der kinder stand ein einem
künstler in künstlerkreisen unterwegs zu
sein die frau die mutter selbst an sich
die täterin ist auch noch nicht in
erscheinung getreten wie wir gerade
jetzt eben erfahren haben war sie auch
nur zu besuch hier und wohnt eigentlich
irgendwo im taunus und das macht das
ganze natürlich auch noch mal viel
dramatischer
[Musik]